so
you're starting a new chapter of sorts
in your life the view is in the rear
view mirror now what made this the
perfect project for you to produce on
and move forward with
well i'd always been a fan of the book
don't sweat the small stuff it's sort of
like a
manifesto it's like a you know i don't
like to say self-help but it's like a
guidebook uh in a really simple way to
live your life to the fullest and it has
always resonated with me sometimes it
feels like dad's death hasn't affected
you at all all the things that richard
and i lived by seek first to understand
make peace with imperfection maybe
there's a lesson in all of us i
rediscovered it after my dad died and
when i found out that there was a
possibility that it was going to be
turned into a movie um i thought hey
like incredible i'm going to watch it no
matter what because i'm just such a fan
and be it something i would really love
to be a part of so
um it sort of was a
like a perfect storm of things and
uh the project came to me when i was
actually still at the view um but it has
been serendipitous that this is like my
first project out of the gate because
i love politics and i will always do
things in politics obviously but i also
one of my just like goals right now is
to start creating content or being a
part of content and projects where
anybody it doesn't matter your political
affiliation can consume it and i think
in this time postcovid where um you know
the majority of americans know someone
who has you know sadly died of coved um
finding things that are about grief and
moving forward and healing
it's been amazing to be able to be a
part of something that i think can
actually bring a lot of healing to a lot
of people i love that you rediscovered
this book because of that loss of your
dad what did the book pop into your mind
did your mom remind you of it how did
that come back to your mind again i
actually googled like books on grief and
po and like healing and it was one of
the things that like popped up on amazon
so and then i was like i should reorder
that and i did and then
i actually found there are some really
if you come to me and you're like i need
books to help with grief there's some
amazing ones like when breath becomes
air um that are i found very healing and
amazing and i think you know we just
it's been a really rough two years for
everyone i don't care who you are you've
had a rough two years and a lot of
people have suffered extreme loss and i
think don't sweat the small stuff and
christine's story in particular is one
that for me i found very hopeful and i
think sometimes when you're in like the
depths and spirals of deep grief it
feels like you're gonna drown and you're
not gonna come out of it and i think her
story is very inspiring for those of us
who you know still i still struggle with
grief but coming out the other side if
that makes sense
so you you've been changed the past
couple years
yeah i say that like i'm still me like
i'm still like feisty and a fighter and
all these things but my dad dying a
brain cancer coveted and having a baby
like if you hadn't come out the other
side of those experiences changed then i
you know i don't think it's even
possible so for me it's just been a
confluence of things where i'm really um
you know not to get too deep but i'm
really been thinking about my mortality
and what i want to do with my life and
what i want my life to look like and
being in a more positive space is a big
is a big part of that it sounds like
you're having a moment of like life's
too short
that's exactly it and again i know how
this sounds like i used to hear people
talk like that and think that they were
like kind of cheesy and ridiculous but
you know i'm pushing middle age too like
you know i think like if you're not
changing and evolving you're not paying
attention like i thought that i was
going to die of covet because i was in
new york city and i was pregnant and
you're obviously higher risk when you're
pregnant and i had to leave the city
because my doctor told me to because he
said it wasn't safe and i just felt like
i could die of this as i think we all
had a moment where we were so scared
when you didn't know enough about the
virus and
i thought and i remember literally when
i was driving out of new york city
having this moment where i was like i
cannot die today because i am so not
finished and this is not the direction i
want to go in in my life and that had a
lot to do with a lot of the choices i
made um you know from that moment past
including producing this movie the cast
you got it's incredible like heather
locklear and natasha what made them the
perfect people for these parts because
heather locklear i mean you cast a
casual icon in this movie and she's so
beloved
yeah i mean who doesn't love heather
locklear i always call her like you know
she's such an american icon and um every
man in my life including my husband is a
you know think she's the most gorgeous
thing that's ever lived which is you
know nice oh i'm amanda woodbird i've
always been a fan of hers from melrose
place on and then you know she's taken a
break from acting and you know she's
gone through struggles of her own and i
thought um that her sort of like rawness
and openness with her struggles would be
something that would be great for the
movie and regards the natasha i mean i
love candace cameron beret she's a
former review co-host as well and i just
think she does really again like feel
good family-friendly things that i think
you know they're so popular the majority
of us watch especially during the
holidays and um you know i'm a
fan of
daughters of famous people continuing in
their family legacy and i just thought
that she was like so amazing and she's a
really great actress and she's really
young and i just love seeing her follow
in her mother's footsteps and how cool
to say you you produce this movie you
know i mean that that's a nice feather
in the cap that's a cool accomplishment
do you feel good about that and how
you're adding to what you've done yeah i
mean i'm like so honored i was honored
that they like allowed me to be a part
of it i was honored that lifetime wanted
to partner with me they did um some
trailer teasers on lifetime where they
were like executed produced by megan
mccain and they're like moments in my
life at least where i feel like you know
their career moments where i still feel
like oh my god like that's the craziest
thing ever and that's one of them where
i was like that looks pretty cool i'm
not hosting i'm an executive producer so
yeah it feels wonderful and
um i don't know i just keep trying to
evolve and keep moving i always say i'm
like a shark you got to keep moving so
i'm really proud that this is now part
of my career
how's the family how's baby girl are we
a little out of the scary time and are
you enjoying being at home
yeah having a daughter that i have this
responsibility to like obviously love
and nurture but i also want her to be
strong and prepared for the world um
it's beautiful and amazing i was so
scared of having children i have a book
coming out in october where i talk about
how i was not excited when i was
pregnant i was really scared i was
really overwhelmed because of covey and
i didn't know what kind of mother i
would be and i thought i really worried
i was gonna hate it and i was gonna like
and now i'm so obsessed with her that i
just like my problem right now is like i
have to go to new york for a few days
for this other thing i'm doing and i i'm
like so sad i have to spend three days
away from her and i was trying to figure
out if i could bring her and like it was
okay with coven and whatever so um i
love it i just feel blessed that i have
the kind of life where i can spend as
much time with her as i can and i just
i don't know i feel i'm really really
really happy right now which
um i feel like i earned because it took
me a long time to get here and also
um i just feel really grateful and
blessed and i know there's a lot of
women that don't have the luxury i do to
be at home when you want to writing a
column and doing things like this and i
feel really lucky and really
just really blessed right now